Did you know that
people are voluntarily
putting tapeworms
inside their bodies?
It's known as the tapeworm diet.
It helps people lose weight
by letting this parasite
eat everything
inside of them.
But this diet can go
very, very wrong.
Well on today's challenge
we're going to find out
by having you
swallow a tapeworm.
Think you can handle it?
Tapeworms are flat,
segmented worms
that can be as long as
25 meters (80 feet).
They can’t live
freely on their own,
they need to be
in the gut
of an animal
or a human to thrive.
Animals can become infected
with these parasites
when grazing in pastures
or drinking contaminated water.
How long do you think
a tapeworm
can live inside your body?
We'll have your answer
later in the episode.
There are two ways to get infected.
The most common
tapeworm infection
is called
You get this
if you eat
undercooked meat or fish
from an infected animal.
The tapeworm larvae
in the animal muscle tissue
would migrate to your gut.
You can also get infected
if you are in contact with
animal faeces
or contaminated water
from an animal with tapeworms.
This type of infection
is known as
You get this
by ingesting
microscopic tapeworm eggs.
It’s rare to get a parasite this way.
But it can happen
in countries
with poor sanitary conditions.
In both scenarios,
you wouldn’t feel a thing.
If you have a cysticercosis infection,
the eggs you ingested
will hatch into mobile larvae
once they've entered your intestines.
They could migrate
out of your intestines
and infect organs
other than the digestive system.
But throughout your first week,
it's likely you won't notice
anything at all.
So let's see what happens
when we keep going.
Let’s go back to the
taeniasis infection.
The tapeworm larva
has developed into
an adult tapeworm.
in your intestines
and can be up to 7 m (23 ft) long.
It attaches to the inner wall
of your intestines
and feeds off the food
you’re digesting.
You could feel nauseous,
have abdominal pain,
diarrhea,
and you'd begin to lose weight.
But it's also very likely that
you wouldn't feel anything at all.
You may find out
you have tapeworms
by taking a closer look at
what you've produced
while on the toilet seat.
At this stage,
pieces of the tapeworm
break off and
exit your body
via your stool.
And they look just like tiny worms.
Gross.
Now that you've finally found out
you have tapeworms.
It's time to go to the doctor.
If you’re diagnosed with taeniasis,
your doctor will prescribe
oral medication for one day.
It would paralyze
the adult tapeworm,
which would let go of the intestine,
dissolve, and
exit your body via your stool.
If the worms are large,
you could have
some stomach cramping
when they pass.
Ok, you managed to escape
a taeniasis infection but
what if you had
cysticercosis instead?
Well, if three months have passed
and you haven't noticed
this infection,
things would get terrible.
A stomach cramp or
sudden weight loss would be
the last thing you're worried about.
That's because the mobile larvae
that have migrated
throughout your entire body
are mature enough to form cysts
in tissues like your lungs,
brain, eyes, or liver.
These cysts could
grow large enough
to crowd the functioning parts
of the organ or
reduce its blood supply.
You could have headaches or
or allergic reactions.
You might experience seizures
in extreme cases.
To get rid of these worms,
you would need surgery
or an organ transplant.
And even after 20 years,
it's still possible
that the tapeworm
could live inside of you,
without you even knowing.
And your buddy could measure
more than 25 m (80 ft) long.
And if the tapeworm
continued to grow,
you would eventually experience
a digestive problem
as it blocks your appendix
or pancreatic ducts.
So tapeworms are horrible
and creepy, and
you don't want them
anywhere near you,
regardless of the easy weight loss.
Speaking of weight loss,
how about the opposite?
Like gaining 300 lb (136 kg)
in a single year?
Well,
we'll see what that challenge brings
on another episode of